out of your mind here's the debate
you're upset
all right so podcast episode number 166
we didn't have any podcast last week
we're back baby we are fully back we got
some guests with two special guests
today with a lot of topics to discuss
we have uh potentially the greatest
marketer ever in politics he could have
been a cmo at a fortune 100 company
and if his father was a gangster from an
italian family he could have been a boss
okay and that's roger stone but uh many
call him a uh uh one of the greatest
political lobbyists of all time whether
you love him or hate him he's very very
good at what he does an absolute
strategist
uh roger it's good to have you here
great to be there and we also have uh uh
rick prado here with us for those of you
that don't know who rick prado is
24-year vet with the cia he served in
the operations uh
uh officer in six overseas posts he was
a deputy chief of station and plank
owner of the original bin laden task
force issues stationed under senior
analyst michael schur
and he was also chief operations in the
cia counter-terrorist center ctc during
the september 11 attacks 9 11 attacks
where prado helped coordinate
cia special operations activities with
the national security council and the
fbi as well as the elite u.s military
representatives from delta force seal
team six
then detailed to ctc thank you for being
on as well and you run a company today
right co-owner of camp x yeah yes it's a
training facility for uh our special
operations forces yes so so there
there's a lot of uh
there's a lot of things going on that we
can cover today that has to do with your
background and as well as has to do with
your background i'm curious to know what
your positions have changed with
presidency coming into 2023 2024 if you
were a uh the people in vegas who are
looking at odds on who could be the
president they're probably curious to
know who you think has a shot at being
president you saw uh trump years ago
when he was in his 40s and he said this
guy's got what it takes to be president
one day you ended up being right people
thought you were crazy but it is what it
is
uh and and one of roger's favorite lines
that stuck with me after the first time
we did an interview i love what you said
you said there is
four phases we all go through right
who is roger stone okay
get me roger stone on
get me someone like roger stone and then
who is roger stone right we all kind of
go through that phase and we'll process
that but uh folks if you're uh on here
um we have a lot of topics to cover let
me kind of give you an idea what topics
we're going to be discussing today
before we go through our first
sponsorship and then uh we'll get right
into it first topic we'll get into
is i just put it as clarence thomas i
mean obviously i know with supreme court
i know it's roe v wade but it's you know
clarence thomas has done a lot of things
in the last making a lot of headlines a
lot of headlines and he's not slowing
down he seems like he wants to go after
the lgbt the you know the same sex
marriage
he's talking about morning after pill
people are losing their minds riots
protesting all over the country we'll
talk about that number two we'll talk
about what happened with russia
uh going into default mode and then at
the same time g7 nations to announce ban
on russian gold as moscow sanctions
widen and then putin
says warns london
will be bombed first if a world war
three was was to break out and then
topic number three will be trump
uh bill maher uh claims trump could win
easily because of drag queens but he
can't let go of the election kirsten
know what you think about that
more than a million voters have switched
to republican party in the last year
that's a new york post story
and then uh a uh apparently a big fist
fight broke out with rudy giuliani i
don't know apparently a big fist fight
broke out with rudy giuliani i don't
know if you guys saw that or not it was
something that happened that guy rudy
took it though i don't know how he did
by the way it's it's either nancy
pelosi's elbow or rudy getting padded in
the back we got to talk about that
and then biden says we have to prepare
for the next pandemic we need funding
for the next pandemic which maybe a
former ci agent has some information we
don't know about and last but not least
retirement
savers have lost three trillion dollars
in the stock market that's three
trillion dollars in the stock market
that's been lost we'll cover all that
and some more stories but let me get
into so a quick sponsorship here
and why we chose to get these guys as
our core one of our main sponsors uh on
the pbd podcast and that's oral let me
explain to you why we
chose this first of all
you know if you yourself are doing what
you're doing on a daily basis we all
know the fastest growing crime in
america right now is identity identity
theft it's happening every 14 seconds
for the first time in the u.s history
theft from cybercrime in the u.s exceeds
that from bur you know robbery i myself
have gone through this multiple times
with social with credit cards it happens
regularly nowadays matter of fact what i
love about these guys or what they're
doing is you can actually go test to see
how many times your personal information
is used on the dark web some of our guys
here did it and one of our guys aaron
went and tested it out he saw that his
his password his personal information
has been used on a dark web 30 plus
times
yeah what i love about these guys you
can go find out how many times your own
password and personal information has
been used before so if it's happened to
me can happen to you that's why i'm
excited to partner with aura aura who is
sponsoring this video auras identity
theft protection fraud monitoring the
vpn password management and anti-virus
software all combined into one easy to
use app you may have one of these tools
but not having all of them is like
locking the front door but leaving the
back door wide open
aura monitors the dark web for your
emails password and social security
numbers and sends alerts fast right to
your phone and email when it comes to
fraud every second matters connect your
credit card and bank accounts and get
notified of any changes up to four times
faster than aura competitors that's
insane their vpn allows you to stay
anonymous online by keeping your
browsing history and personal
information safe and encrypted and their
antivirus software will block malware
malware and viruses before they infect
your devices if you're a traveling
person you're an executive you
definitely want to check this out and uh
for the folks that are listening to the
pvd podcast the first 14 days is a free
trial protect yourself and uh with uh
from the fastest grown crime try aura
free for two weeks and see if any of
your family's personal information has
been compromised visit aura aura dot com
forward slash pbd one more time a u r a
dot com forward slash pbd for your 14
day free trial having said that let's
get right into it i figured the first
topic we we could go to roe v wade but i
figured it's appropriate for us to go
maybe into the trump topic first and
address that because you know roger if
you don't mind most of the world who's
in the political world knows who you are
but some don't
can you take a minute and give everyone
your background of what you've done in
politics the next 30 the last 30 40
years wow
well i've i have worked on 11 national
presidential campaigns starting with
richard nixon three campaigns for
governor ronald reagan later president
ronald reagan
worked in the u.s senate for
senator bob dole one of the greatest men
of the 20th century uh did uh service
for uh george w bush uh and then of
course uh donald trump
uh i am uh i'm a trump supporter i make
that very clear i think i may have been
among the earliest people in the country
to see his potential as not only a great
presidential candidate but a great
president he certainly changed history
in many ways
i do think people
underestimate the extent to which he
dominates the republican party at the
grassroots level
not among the party leaders
those are the guys who like with reagan
had to pretend they liked him because he
was so popular among their voters
but this is still his party he has
transformed the party from being the
party of
country club elites to being the party
of working-class people
based largely on his economic record
uh and therefore i think he's in a
commanding position if he wants to run
again
i think he does want to run again i
actually think his announcement of
candidacy may come as early as july this
july uh for a couple of reasons
one of course is
the ongoing effort by the democrats to
disqualify him
fabricate some crime that would that
prevent him from running clearly what
they're trying to do in connection to
january 6th
and also there are you know he has a
rival out there our own governor ron
desantis who's made it pretty clear that
he might want to try to take on the
champ
the national polls
show that trump would prevail in that
contest as well but
um i think he's highly likely uh to run
again
he's highly likely to run again i
believe and and there's two camps
there's a camp that says desantis won't
run directly against trump and there's a
camp that says no he's gonna run because
the opportunity is so hot right now for
desantis with the record he's at in
florida the last two years this is a
perfect time for for him to run where do
you stand with that first of all he
needs to get himself reelected he's got
a contest this november uh he should not
take that for granted i think he's
favored but
florida's not a red state and it's not a
blue state it's a purple state
and the governor's poll is very popular
i'm certainly going to vote for his
reelection but he's also very polarizing
so
you know richard nixon lost the
presidency in 1960
decided to run for governor in 1962 on
his way to the 64 nomination
something went wrong he didn't get
elected governor and that was the end of
that comeback attempt interesting
desantis i think would be wise to pay
attention to the contest before him uh
before he gets ahead of himself
uh this is uh
i i he would be a formidable candidate i
don't deny that um but uh he is he
doesn't have the charisma that trump has
he doesn't have the the uh the presence
that
that trump has
the governor is very good in a
controlled atmosphere when he has the
microphone and nobody else does he does
great
but he's not self-deprecating he's not
funny he's not entertaining he's kind of
stiff
he said trump's self-deprecating
all the time yeah absolutely trump makes
jokes about himself and you say desantis
is kind of a stiff kind of a stiff i
mean he's very focused he's very
disciplined which is a key factor in
politics but he's not very charismatic
he's a little boring he's a little
boring is care is charisma the most
important quality a president could have
we live in the television age you know
they asked ronald reagan
do you think it was detrimental to your
your your prospects to be president that
you were an actor and he said you know
i don't see how a guy who wasn't an
actor could ever do this job this is in
1980
when he was president
i don't see someone who's not an actor
can do this job can you imagine that
line for reagan to say which which makes
sense okay rick in the the trump camp
where do you stand on this you live in
florida so you probably have strong
opinions on desantis trump all that well
i i voted for trump both times i think
that he has put together the best
policies for this country i love his
patriotism
i love his support for law enforcement
and of course for our military special
military and law enforcement and federal
agencies
um
i also like desantis i think that he's
done an incredible job here in florida
um and i've talked to a lot of people
about this a lot of people don't want
the centers to run because they don't
want him to leave florida
it's a very selfish place it has been
very vocal about that yeah that's that's
a big concern a lot of floridians have
but i think i think the biggest question
is the following and and i'm curious to
know what you say about this so you know
how uh uh in mma or in boxing certain
people that come from the same camp you
know they don't fight each other and
then if they do there's a big you know a
rift there's a big follow now between
the two yeah mass vidal had a following
out with kobe they used to come from the
same camp so if you follow mma you're
both you know you so you hear stories
like that
what what do you so visualize the stage
which is what everybody is
wanting to see if it's going to happen
or not oh first republican you know
presidential debate on the republican
side okay so we're looking at all the
candidates on stage you're going to see
say rubio maybe cruz you see all the
candidates that we see right they're on
the stage maybe mayor suarez i don't
know but you got these names on the
stage right they're debating
everybody knows it's really two names
it's not any other names the other guys
are up there just to kind of be up there
but we know it's only two names
do you remember the the scene when
kamala harris went right after biden do
you remember that one scene when kamala
hurst went after bussing back in
and then surprisingly she ends up
becoming a vp which is a very weird
thing that happens but
what happens when these two go at it you
know what happens when they call each
other out who calls each other who calls
who out first
how is the market going to take it how
are republicans going gonna take it how
are democrats gonna use it
how are the other side gonna be prepared
let's just say trump takes a shot at
desantis is desantis gonna come out
strong towards trump if desantis comes
out first and takes a shot at trump is
trump gonna come out and bully him like
he typically does is that good for the
party have they spoken prior
are they going to call each other out
and say listen hey desantis we know it's
you and i
uh let's take it easy on each other is
that going to be the conversation or is
trump going to say no i'm not going to
do that we're going at it who's going to
win how do you see this happening well
there's not too many questions there
first of all it's two years from now and
two years
is a lifetime in politics a month is a
lifetime in politics
governor sanchez did not fare very well
in his two debates with mayor gillum
again an uncontrolled atmosphere
he does very well in a controlled
atmosphere where he has the podium and
the microphone trump will be
entertaining always entertaining
and that's that's very important uh in
our culture i mean politics is
entertainment the worst thing in
politics to be is boring trump is never
boring
um but to handicap something that's two
years from now is extraordinarily
different uh difficult
well you did that 30 years though you
you handicapped 30 years prior to trump
being president i was disabled that's
even more difficult i was just actually
able to see a you know a prime piece of
political horse flash i was prepared to
see a guy who i thought had the size i
don't mean the physical size but the
presence uh and the courage and the
stamina uh
and the willingness to say anything to
be an interesting uh and provocative not
only candidate but then have the courage
to be a strong president
trump
broke the mold i mean before trump
we had no president who wasn't a general
or a senator or a governor
we never had a business person as
president so
on paper trump shouldn't be able to win
he broke all of the rules didn't spend
millions of dollars on network
television advertising still got elected
president so um i still think he's the
favorite
on the other side of the coin
not to not to shock you but my
prediction on the democratic nominee for
president in 2024
michelle obama
almost certainly i agree uh you're
saying most certainly yeah i i mean this
book tour she said yesterday yeah she
does
yeah she's out there being very go ahead
she's very active right now she's out
doing this book tour these voter
registration drives and so on she's
certainly not doing for the money so
no i think she's positioning herself and
by the way i think she'll be a very
formidable candidate do you think she
could beat trump
too far away um are gas prices the same
as they are today or do we have food
shortages are we still dying from this
rampant inflation uh are we are we
shipping 40 billion dollars to ukraine
when we can't spend five and a half
point six seven million to seal our
southern border i mean the the issue
situation today would favor any
republican in the at least in the next
election round and perhaps the following
round but again reagan had a sour
economy in the middle of his first term
the economy was roaring by the end of
his first term and he got reelected so
meaning if things change and powell
increasing the rates doing what he does
maybe flattens in
inflation and then he can lower interest
rates a little bit so then we go back to
having a decent economy
and gas prices go lower everything is
now a little bit more settled you think
the likelihood of biden getting
re-elected
is higher or you just don't think he's
going to run again i don't see him
running again okay
so no matter what on the left it's going
to be somebody else outside of biden is
what you're saying that is my belief
yeah do you also agree absolutely who do
you think it's going to be
i don't know and the news of michelle
obama scares me because she is um i
consider her a very drastic uh left-wing
individual
um you know from from my and i'm not a
politician that's obvious but for from
my perspective
you know the the far right is always
going to vote for right and the far left
is always going to vote left so we need
a candidate especially in our republican
party somebody that could bring in that
middle america
you know that average american out there
that finally cannot afford to be the
silent majority anymore and become a
that's so silent majority
so are you are you going to when you
said that are you saying desantis is
that kind of where you were going with
them no neither one either one
i um
let the best man win but i know which
way i would be voting would be still
that way but but let me ask you a
question roger from your from your uh
having done this for a while how often
do do candidates leading candidates of
the same party talk to each other before
the first debate
oh almost always and what does that call
sound like what's that conversation
sound like
you know it can be like the way off in a
in a prize fight you know they can trash
talk each other or but i think the
i think the president's kind of
nonchalant about this he quoted the new
yorker last week as saying look it's his
prerogative if he runs he runs i'll beat
him
i think that's the right attitude
got it but it's not deals are not made
pre or our deals made pre-first
debate that takes place i don't think
anybody makes a deal because everybody
goes into that debate thinking i'm the
guy
this is my opportunity to break through
maybe i'm back in the pack right now but
this is my opportunity to break through
the field of winnow pretty close pretty
quickly because
trump is so completely dominant the only
one as you correctly pointed out
who potentially is a challenger who can
get anything together uh is ron desantis
i mean
mike pompeo go out on the street in
front of the uh of the studio and that's
the first seven people you see who mike
pompeo is they don't even know who marco
rubio is and we live in florida
that's pretty so so this is a
complete different question about since
we're on this year so so far three names
which i fully agree on those three names
uh
michelle obama you got trump you got
desantis great but
let's talk about wild cards okay and
wild cards are somebody we least expect
okay
uh there were talks of a
rock saying hey one day
you know he wouldn't mind becoming the
president you hear logan paul and jake
paul talk about they're going to be
presidents logan paul to me i think that
guy's got a big upside he's
he's entertaining he's smart he's good
looking he's a good talker
he's a great marketer he's a good
storyteller but he's young right but in
a
setting where a dwayne johnson the rock
my opinion this is a perfect time for
him to run if he wants to win now
politically whether you agree with him
or this is not about politics i'm not
asking policies i'm asking timing-wise
the left doesn't have an exciting
candidate okay the right
is confused between two different
candidates if there's ever been a time
for a guy like to jump in there whether
you like his policies or not it's
irrelevant do you think this would be a
good time for the rock to make a move uh
it's a tremendous advantage
uh in american politics particularly
presidential panics to begin
well known
ronald reagan had a career before
politics donald trump had a career
before politics so they were both able
in a way to skip the step the first step
of politics which has become well known
candidates like the rock begin well
known now i'm not sure which party he's
in
i'm not really clear what his politics
are
but it is not inconceivable that he
could be a viable candidate because he
has that elusive quality he's got
celebrity quality he's extremely well
known that's an excellent leg up it's
one of the principal reasons why trump
was able to be nominated so so if we do
match-ups we do match-ups you know how
you
see the boxing match up 74 inch rage
versus 72 and a half height weight 178
was okay let's zoom at the tail of the
table exactly right so
so you got the rock versus reagan reagan
was a b
level actor he wasn't an a he but he'd
been governor and and he had a very
significant okay so that's governor
perfect so fair enough so that's the age
so the rock somebody could say
highest paid actor right he's made his
money
uh he's got god knows how many followers
on social media he's an international
figure so he's got that part
um then if you look at some of the other
names if you compare him to trump well
trump wins on success of business
you know what he's built his brand but
the rock may win for you know being more
famous
policies trump's been talking policies
since the 80s i don't know if the rock's
been talking politics for 30 years so
that's the one part where he has even he
himself said this is not an area where i
excellent but all i'm asking is in a
situation like this
if you got a call from one of these guys
from one of their handlers saying hey we
want this thing to be
you know we want you to sign an nda and
we don't want you to say this to anybody
we are willing to hire you as a you know
political
uh strategist but no one knows this
if feedback was given to them what would
you say to some of these guys you want
to be president run for governor you
want to be president run for senator in
other words trump would run on a
four-year record of unprecedented
economic growth rebuilt of our building
of our military appointments scores of
conservatives to the court he's got a
record to run on i don't think you can
go from actor to president without an
intermediate step reagan had two terms
as governor of california very
successful terms that's what qualified
him to be president
his his
presence obviously his charisma made him
a strong candidate but it was the record
that mattered crazy question for you if
arnold was born in u.s could he have
been a president
he may have been of course his politics
shifted over time right so he started as
a reagan republican he ended up as a
kennedy democrat right right that's not
too far removed though these days these
days yeah that's true from 40 yard line
to 40 yard line is the way i would is is
there anybody else you see there that's
a wild card that has a shot at uh
you know shaking things up in 2024. i i
don't see it but yeah and it's it's two
years from now it's very hard to say two
years is a long time of politics it is
really a month is a long time okay all
right well listen i'm talking to the guy
that predicted things 30 years ago i
thought maybe you had that mojo today
going to tell us some things but we can
go to basically some of what we got some
vegas people on here what our friend
roger stone is saying is that i think
you once said it is better to be
infamous than to never be famous at all
i did say that and you are uh would you
is it fair to say that you are living in
infamy uh i am today yes thanks to the
folks at cnn you may have just them you
may have seen my early morning cnn tv
show i had 29 fbi co-stars yeah it was a
great show
they're all carrying fully automatic m4
assault weapons to arrest a 68 year old
man with no priors for the uh for the
white-collar crime of lying to congress
which i wasn't even guilty of how do you
lie about russian collusion when there
is no russian collusion not possible
did you have a follow-up i'm i'm waiting
for you to see if you're well it's like
where you're going somewhere with i feel
like we're there's a couple there's many
different directions you know i've asked
many friends i got roger stone coming on
you wouldn't believe the wildly
different opinions i have i wrote some
of them down some said he's a national
treasure and he's a american hero
some says that guy's not in jail some
says that guy is a treasonous and he
should be locked up
why are you such a polarizing figure uh
because i tell you what i really think
uh because i've beaten a lot of
democrats in elections uh because uh i
believe in loyalty look i was charged
for one reason to pressure me to testify
falsely against trump i refused to do
that
that that aggravated a lot of people and
i was marked for destruction uh it is
only through an act of mercy and justice
that the president pardoned my uh
pardon me in my conviction but
two years after i was convicted by court
order
uh robert mueller and the doj are forced
to release the redacted section they
report in which they admit they never
had any evidence against me of russian
collusion or wikileaks collaboration
or any other uh criminal act so uh no i
think good to half the people i'm a hero
to the atheist people it's a villain uh
i've at least made my mark it's better
than being no one
yeah the uh so you're comfortable being
the villain to half of america i don't i
don't have any choice it's not a
question whether i'm comfortable with it
or not i do i do find it odd
uh that violence has become uh you know
has become acceptable i went to a
restaurant and i saw someone across the
room that i disagreed with politically i
wouldn't start screaming or throwing
things at them or threatening them i'd
ignore them but that that is that is not
the case today and public shaming uh and
violence are all too common i can't
leave south florida without a
professional security it's not violent
not viable not viable some may say that
you were the the head of the snake for
the how ugly politics is today
uh you started what they call negative
uh campaign advertising um
do you you feel any sort of like um
i'm not gonna say remorse but like
or maybe it's pride that you were kind
of the originator of how dirty politics
is or has it always been this dirty but
you've been sort of nicknamed this dirty
trickster even though that's not the
terminology you use but they use for you
i think you once said on your tombstone
it's not going to say what you describe
yourself as the agent provocateur you're
certainly provocative um but it'll
likely say dirty trickster however you
don't use those words correct so how
would you explain that uh you know
abraham lincoln's opponents handed out
leaflets saying that he was a mixed race
i'm sorry i didn't i didn't invent naked
politicians you weren't around in the
lincoln days
i was not the head of youth for lincoln
uh the point i'm making is that politics
has always been a contact sport in
america uh i i didn't change that i'm
not responsible for that i have always
played uh the game by the rules and the
laws by which it is regulated as
politics has changed you have to change
got it right question for you and roger
i'd like to get your commentary on this
as well i was speaking to a friend of
mine who's a also former ci agent
yesterday when i got back and i asked
him a question i said so
when it comes on to these agencies fbi
and cia right
where do they recruit from do they
recruit people from
these big yale schools they go to you
know these big
ivy league schools and they're picking
people up from there and if they do
most of them are indoctrinated in one
side politically
but their job is to protect everybody
how often did you see in the cia or in
the fbi
the individual person's political
leanings influenced their decision
making in their job
i never really saw it i think that that
is a new trend uh part of the issue that
i have is
you know our federal agencies need to be
headed by people that were part of that
agency
political appointees do not do well as
ahead of something that they don't
understand if you've never been in a car
meeting with a terrorist in a dark alley
how can you make decisions that that
that affect me on the street
so i think the politicizer of our agency
is part of the problem you have people
that go in there they're political
appointees they owe alliance
to whoever allowed them to go in there
rather than to those people that that
the work for him or her
roger what do you think about what
richard said i think the vast majority
of rank and file fbi and cia
employees and agents or honest people
who have no politics the political
corruption is at the top
of the of those agencies
when
when fbi agents agents are raiding the
home of journalists to find out whether
they have a copy of joe biden's
daughter's diary i think that i think
that's crossing a line when fbi agents
are
arraigning the home of the number three
guy at the department of justice because
he held a different legal opinion than
others i don't think i don't think
that's i don't think that's appropriate
yeah you're talking about james o'keefe
when they yeah o'keefe and in this case
um
uh jeffrey
clark jeffrey clark the fbi director the
doj yeah i i wonder when i think about
uh uh
by the way the two parties
can you pull up to see which which not
parties the two agencies which agency
does america trust more ciao or fbi
i'm curious who's trusted more do you
guys know these stats or no
are you familiar like if if i were to
ask you and if i was that so you're not
a part of it at all before they say
anything
do you trust the cia more do you trust
the fbi folks if you're listening as
well i'm curious comment below do you
trust the fbi more the cia more
what would you say
uh
just on the sheer fact that you've heard
the cia might have been responsible for
the kennedy association
just because of that i would lean
towards the fbi but i think they both
these days have
a damaged reputation well what is that
public holds positive views across 10
federal agencies departments number one
is what postal service favorable
seriously have they been to the post
office
cdc
this is positive or unfavorable
seventy eight percent now this is 2018.
okay
[Music]
well then if you look at this fbi ncaa
is pretty much around the same thing
okay
i'd love to see what this is in 2022
because america the world has changed in
four years
i actually think what you would find is
that
the public has a distrust of all
political institutions both parties
congress the fbi the cia the media
that's a fairly new development i think
that there is a fundamental distrust of
all of our institutions
by the american people
do you have some thoughts on this yeah i
do i really do you know that is the
reason why i wrote black ops because i
got so tired
of my agency being maligned in hollywood
we're not
jason bourne we're not american made
um
those things assassinating kennedy uh
you know
these are you know rumors and stuff that
goes out there part of the political
game
you know the agency is put together by
literally from all the classes we
recruit a lot from the military because
former military is has a lot more
diversity
they have languages remember we the
united the cia we do not operate in the
united states
we're not allowed to operate in the
united states
um
so all our work is done overseas
so for that you need people that can fit
in in different
geographical areas without causing
attention because everything that we do
is
black ops under the shadow of darkness
or that we cannot afford for our mission
to be compromised rick you made a
comment earlier you said i'm
uncomfortable with folks who are not
from cia or fbi to be directors of the
city fbi
and if you've never sat there negotiated
with a terrorist you you don't know what
it's like to sit there negotiating with
a terrorist
that statement means that you have
you've sat there and negotiated with
terrorists yes i have
are you able to name some of the folks
you've sat down with and have
negotiations with no uh i could tell you
that i did recruit and uh no one's
watching this by the way
yeah i know you
i did recruit a terrorist in a latin
american country which i wasn't allowed
to say in the book
um but it was a member of a maoist
insurgency okay and i literally
recruited this guy under coercion um
i had a police officer friend we
we busted him i was i had that you know
alias documentation with me
and um
you know the guy decided to cooperate
because we made him an offer they
couldn't refuse you know he would be in
in jail for the rest of his life
and i ran this guy for a good year and
he gave us some incredible information
um
so yeah i have done that and my point is
the fbi should be led
by a senior fbi individual that
understands those laws that understands
the culture
uh and understands the trials that that
our officers uh you know go through
interesting
uh well you know i never forget my dad
pulled me aside eight years ago seven
years ago something like that
uh we have some people in our family who
have done some work you know from iran
so iran had savak and different kind of
things that they were dealing with back
in the days
he sits me down and says he winks and he
says you can tell me
i said i can tell you what that
he says you can tell me it's okay it's
just you know
dad what i'm gonna tell you he says i
know you're with the cia just wink just
say one thing but i know you are so dad
i'm just an insurance guy says no you're
not i don't believe you yeah we all saw
true lies but yeah
how do you think the uh current director
of the cia i believe his name is william
burns how do you think he's doing you
know he he has a good reputation as an
ambassador
uh and he's always had a very cordial
and supportive um
posture overseas when dealing with our
chiefs of stations that's his reputation
it's a guy that appreciates the cia but
you know if you're going for eye surgery
you don't go to a knee doctor
and that's my point you know you've got
to have somebody that has been there
even
half a degree to understand what our job
is all about
roger when's the last time you sat this
close to someone affiliated with the cia
it's hard to say there might be there
might be shadowing
next to two potential cia
right
so so let me let me go through the story
of bill maher said i want to get your
commentary your thoughts on this so bill
maher claims trump could win so easy
because of drag queens
but he can't let go of the election this
is a mediator story comic component bill
maher claimed that the former president
trump could win easy because of drag
queens but can't let go of elections on
friday night edition of hbo's real time
with bill maher the host
uh took a table bit about future
headlines that included libraries in
texas to offer impotent gun nut story
hour to banter with guests andrew
sullivan and katie herzog about what a
drag culture issues like a drag queen
story hour are on democrats
mara explained that poor trump could
easily win if he could let go to 2020
because of the drag queens do you agree
with him i'm a little upset with bill
first of all because he had me on
maligned me as a russian spy
now he himself admits there was no
russian collusion but he won't have me
back on you know why i'm way funnier
than he is way funnier you think you're
funnier
no no when you go to bill maher's show
they take you in your dressing room uh
and his producer comes and says well
great to have you please give me one
favor don't try to be funnier than bill
i said bill's got an entire you know
group of writers who are cranking out of
stuff yeah i'm all by myself they ask
you to do that oh yeah absolutely no
look i've been on bill's show several
times yeah and it's always lively and
he's entertaining it's not the drag
queens of the reason trump can win it's
gas prices food shortages
inflation
leaving several billion dollars worth of
equipment in afghanistan shipping 40
billion dollars off to ukraine when we
can't spend the money to seal our own
border those are the reasons that he can
win
the the 2020 election is kind of tricky
it would be false to say that people are
not concerned about it that doesn't mean
it's going to get undone or redone or
that's not realistic but but
voter integrity the integrity of the
roles that's a legitimate issue
and i don't think trump can stop talking
about it in that sense you think he
should uh in terms of the fact that our
next election needs to be honest fair
and transparent yes absolutely no no do
you think he should stop bringing up
that there was fraud in the last
election do you think he needs to just
move on and focus on today's issue it's
the precursor to insisting that there be
no fraud in the next election so i don't
think i don't think it should be the
reis and detroit to his candidacy
because politics is not is never about
the past it's always about the future
let me ask you a question on bill maher
because i watch his show religiously or
you know you might say religiously or
whatever his uh you know thing is but
when you sit down with him you're not on
the panel typically with the last time i
saw you did the one-on-one yes the yeah
sort of like the pre-game to the show
yes and it's really almost like i don't
want to say an interrogation but he's
he's coming right at you and whatever
your talking points are he's going to
dismiss them and
get to his point so sitting down with
bill maher
you must have seen how he's sort of
what does he famously say these days uh
pat i haven't changed the democratic
party has changed they've moved a little
bit far left uh what have you seen him
uh
update his opinions what what's your
take on bill maher these days because a
lot of people are basically saying hey
you know what this bill maher i never
really agreed with him
it's kind of making sense these days are
you starting to see more of that on some
issues i think he's been very consistent
and i agree with him so for example he's
always been a critic of radical muslim
he's always been critical of islamic
terrorism he's always been pro-cannabis
legalization position i've held for 30
years he's smoking his joints on the
regular as a as a libertarian um i do
think that he's come around on the
hypocrisy of the american left so yeah a
lot of my conservative friends are like
have a new appreciation for bill maher
do you
uh yeah i do i think he's been i think
he's being honest
why won't he have you back home uh
because he doesn't want to get bested
again oh you think so
anytime i think bill mark can handle you
though at any time
you hear that bill maher roger stone on
the pbd podcast and valuetainment is
calling you out he wants to see us again
by the way on top of that more than a
million voters have switched the
republican party in the last 24 in the
last 12 months
and that's a big number including tens
of thousands of swing vote voters and
some declaring they can no longer
support the democratic party policies
according to report monday the move to
the gop is occurring in every part of
the country
in democratic and republican states and
cities since president biden defeated
former president trump in analysis of
voter registration data by associated
press found over the past year about
two-thirds of 1.7 million voters who
changed party affiliation shifted to the
republican party and overall more than
one million people become republicans
compared to 630 000 who became democrats
why do you think that is
uh the as i think it was james carville
said it's the economy stupid i mean yeah
it's gas i think it's that simple yes i
i really do you had a boom economy you
had the most robust economy in our
history under trump you had uh record
job growth record wage growth
billions of dollars coming back in the
country to be invested here
uh
you had an optimism in the country
people's businesses at the small
business level doing extraordinarily
well
now you have apprehension about gas
prices about food shortages
rampant inflation i mean i went to
publix the other day and i bought a
steak
the state cost me seven and a half bucks
it was four bytes it was the smallest
state i've ever seen in my entire life
so uh yeah i i think that that has a lot
to do with it i think that there are
there's no question that there are
buyer's remorse substantial number of
people who
voted for biden because they didn't like
trump's style
oh he's so crude his tweets are so crude
yeah but how's how's your business how
my business is doing great so uh i think
that's this is the manifestation of that
you think people are starting to realize
that and process it where they're saying
okay listen i can't publicly say this
but i i kind of wish the other guy was
president right now you know minus the
stuff that he was doing on twitter i'm
willing to tolerate him more than i'm
willing to tolerate joe or are people
saying there's no way in the world that
could support somebody like him
they're both at this point extremely
polarizing figures
uh but i do think that there is a
there is certain some nostalgia for
trump's economy that that is for sure
what would you say biden has done right
has biden gotten anything right since he
became president
can't think of anything
what about the new gun laws that have
been passed what about the um
uh infrastructure bill none of that i
think the infrastructure bill was first
of all has nothing to do with
infrastructures has to do with spending
it's one of the reasons why we have the
inflation we have today i think red flag
laws are unconstitutional it's just my
opinion
you want to weigh in on this right a
little bit i i first of all i totally
agree with you i think the american
people vote sometimes for charisma but
at the end of the day you're going to
vote with your wallet
the average american cannot make ends
meet anymore
whether they were democrat or republican
before
uh this is something that you know our
survival is our family and how do you
take care of your family if gas is five
dollars a gallon
so for for that for that part i totally
agree with you on the on the gun stuff
um
that is such a political football uh and
it shouldn't be because you gotta look
at the real facts
every city that has the highest crime
rate in the united states
also has the strongest
anti-gun laws
then you go to places like wyoming
montana even florida and some in some
areas and crime is down
because people can defend themselves you
know that that combination uh you you
were talking about uh
biden doing something right let me tell
you something that i think that it is
borders on the ridiculous you go from
saying that crime is rampant
you're allowing crime to be go rampant
you're not persecuting
criminals you're releasing them this is
a catch and release i can fishing
um
and
how do you how does that make sense to
anybody
defund the police
so you're telling me that you who do not
like guns and are not willing or able to
take care of yourself who are you going
to rely on
the police
and you're voting
for to defund your safety net that's
like buying a parachute on ebay
what about you pat is there anything
that you can find uh compelling with
biden these days i know you've been
pretty vocal you're not exactly a biting
guy but
you you you do have the ability to
reason you're not like
set in your uh
views but you so you guys
unbiased so let me tell you how and this
this is going to sound like uh
this but it's not the less i see the
president the more excited i am
i don't want to see the president
because to me it's like stay awake go to
show up and lead don't get up and
complain so
the benefit of him not being comfortable
on stage speaking is a good thing
because we don't hear him often so he's
not out there talking all the time
which is a good thing because when he
does talk america doesn't look good when
he talks would you be comfortable if you
found out that maybe susan rice or
barack obama are kind of
pulling the strings behind the scenes
would you be comfortable with that
so you're asking policies if you're
asking policies i don't support his
policies
i don't support what policies he's got
in place because i don't think his
policies are advancing people by the way
a million votes to voters to flip flip
from what that means democrats became
republicans what are we talking about
here i mean that's not a small number by
the way well and pat if you think about
that break down that number that's just
a broad number where are they coming
from they're coming from the latino
community and the black community
joe biden is losing black support he's
losing latino support the base of the
democratic party is flipping they are
going to lose everything if they keep
this up this is right this is the
greatest significant realignment for the
first time in the country ever
hispanics say they split down the middle
republican democrat that's never
happened before
and the reality is
that under trump you had the highest
rate of job growth and wage growth among
african americans the lowest
unemployment rates and you had criminal
justice reform the first step back the
second chance act so things that the
democrats had talked about
but never enacted look the the the
people i know
who are hispanic or african-american the
parents
of the people i knew when i was in the
military they were all conservative
all of them were like hey son are you
reading the bible are you doing this
are you saying this are you saying that
there were very much conservatives who
were expecting you to be a good man and
not break the law and not do this stuff
same with hispanics
but some of them have been sold a bag of
goods that's not working you know what i
like you you know what i do like on
what's going on
is on the rovi uh way topic which we'll
get into here in a minute is where
people
on the left got upset with kamala harris
to say this is why you need to vote for
us and this is why elections matter and
they said wait a minute
you can do anything you want to do right
now you're not so we voted for you to
get things done and nothing's getting
done so no elections don't matter you
keep telling us to give more money a
democrat was out there
uh this was a video that went viral i
don't know if you saw this or not she
says i'm out here protesting
about roe v wade
and this happened under the watch of a
democratic president who i voted for
and five minutes before i came out here
protesting i got an email from joe biden
and kamala harris telling me to give 15
bucks i've been given 15
but you're not doing anything with my
money how much more money should i give
you so
when your own party turns against you
you got a big problem here and a million
is a big number so if you're asking me
that question
that's a big number we're talking so
address that whatever that person is
they probably just don't understand how
the supreme court works because trump
put in what three justices during his
tenure which is uh no one's ever done
it's not like it's not like
or commonly any control over the supreme
court you're right but what what what
okay so go go with that go with that
what did biden promise to his voters
are you talking about packing the court
go what did biden so people who voted
for trump okay
what did trump promise to people that he
did
what did trump promise what it what was
trump's promise to his voters that he
said if you elect me i'm going to do xyz
what's going to make america great again
he's going to laugh
he's going to build the wall
a lot of three-word phrases
he's going to revive the economy he's
going to rebuild our military he's going
to point conservatives to the judiciary
correct uh he's gonna he's gonna go
negotiate better trade deals everything
he said those things he did those things
what did biden say i'm gonna raise taxes
okay
i'm gonna he hasn't raised back better
he's going to be he has to go back
better he's going to re-enter the paris
uh accords he did that okay so you got
one on his party so i'm just i'm just
thinking of whatever i get that but i
mean he wanted to increase um
multilateralism you know re-engage with
nato obviously trump wasn't a big fan of
nato making them pay yeah
clearly things with nato seem to be
doing a little bit better these days
especially with
the war in ukraine i mean at least
the g7 is on the same page it seems
against russia
what else okay so what you're you got a
party another person's got a party you
vote for your guy it's percentage right
if your policies you say ten things
you're gonna be doing if 80 of them you
do
then the other party elects a guy and
out of 10 things he said he's going to
do he does three of them that's a free
throw percentage 80 wins yeah trump did
more of what he said he was going to do
then biden did what he said he was going
to i agree with you and if and if we
take
cove it out you're president today's
trump by the way you're not wrong i
agree with you here's here's the problem
and i've said this a million times and
and roger stone maybe want to weigh in
on this
trump didn't
lose the election because of
bad policies
it was because of his bad personality
and america was over it straight up we
can we can kind of tap dance around his
personality all we want
but what makes him charismatic to some
makes him unappealing to others not his
policies you could go down the list boom
boom boom boom and if you if you ask
most americans about policies by the way
most americans could not elaborate on
most policies like you said james
carville
let me let me push you people let me
push the economy let me challenge you on
that real quick okay so this is the one
so we're having dinner two nights ago
with a guy heart you know who is heart
and his wife and we're having dinner
with gaines
and andrew and jennifer and i'm sitting
there and i'm bringing up issues to them
like so so let me ask you a question
with such and such thing that clarence
thomas wants to how do you feel about it
how do you feel about transgender how do
you feel about this how do you feel
about that
well you know to each his own and all
this other stuff and i said really yeah
i said okay cool i said at what point
did you form this opinion of to each his
own
i don't know i said 20 years ago would
you have said to each other
uh well yeah
no i don't know i said look here's what
happens
do not let the majority of people the
minority of people who are allowed to
convince you they're the majority so
here's what happened the minority of
people who are complainers
they're like this they come and fight
you in the street and they go like this
you want to fight let me tell you who i
got i got 200 people back to around the
building if you want to fight i'm going
to come and kick your ass and they're
going to come and whoop your ass and
like oh [ __ ] they got 200 people back
there so what do you do you're like dude
i don't want to fight these guys and you
go home right and you go around the
corner they got nobody
they convinced the world they had 200
people around the corner ready to fight
for them so because they're louder
complainers they have convinced even fox
news to do special on transgender
calling that family what an honorable
thing to do what a brave family here
people are falling for
all of these things to say well if
everybody else says it's okay maybe i
should say it as well where the hell is
your backbone or maybe you disagree
and if you disagree people may sit there
and say i i can't believe you said this
i come no problem go for it you can come
at me i'm totally okay with that but
this is my position i'm uncomfortable
with it good for you with agreeing with
the crowd i'm not agreeing with the
crowd so if we do go back
and we ask the question of many people
didn't feel comfortable with trump okay
many people didn't feel comfortable with
desantis
is it true many people didn't
or is it the fact that the people who
said many people didn't are the loudest
complainers and we believe that there
are many people but there's only a few
that's the question and i think people
are starting to realize today when you
see a million people flipping maybe
there were not many people yeah but
you're not going to see 81 million
people flipping so are you basically
well you don't need one million people
we don't have 81 billion you need one
million that's the point midwest that's
the point totally that's the point
but you're making the case that
transgenderism which less than one
percent of america would even identify
one person exactly might even i don't
even know a transgender person you're
not making the comparison that
50 percent of america who's turned off
by trump
you know doesn't really feel that way is
that what you're saying or you're saying
that you're saying people were convinced
that they didn't like him let me let me
let me so so one of my guys asked a
question so pat
uh oh so this guy's running a real
estate office and i'm consulting for him
says pat
i have two guys in my office that are
trans i said okay and how do i handle it
i said what do you mean how do you
handle it i'm in the state of california
how do i handle it
i said what's your point he says they're
making other people feel uncomfortable
and i have a couple people who quit who
are my top producers and i'm worried if
i say something i could go and say
something to the city and then i may get
and then i'm dealing with hr how do i
handle this right okay so
how do you handle that situation how
does an operator handle that situation
does the operator go and say hey man
listen this is too uncomfortable for us
you're making people around you
uncomfortable you got to leave but what
are they doing that's making them
uncomfortable just being there is
uncomfortable
just being there is uncomfortable
because people are coming we live by why
are you why do you have clothes on what
do i have clothes on why does he have a
nice what do we why because we live by
what first impression right i walk into
an office and my first impression is oh
okay huh
interesting what's going on so
people to now you may say pat what's the
big deal with that it doesn't matter
it's a big deal or not we judge but
here's the point
many people in america today aren't
walking on eggshells
people are afraid to say what they
really feel because they may get in
trouble for that and people are getting
sick of that i agree
the fact that yesterday johnny depp's
story whether it's a true story or not
disney may offer the guy 301 million
dollars to get him to play uh uh what do
you call it uh
jack sparrow pirates of the caribbean if
they give this guy 301 million dollars
guess what if he wins guess who won
man's man won men won
this whole thing of trying to pansify
all men to become softer and sissies i
like the fact that johnny depp stood up
not if he didn't stand up
for the rest of us our careers we would
have thought maybe he was a
dirt back on what he did to amber hurt
and we're saying ah you know what what
up the article on valuetainment yeah we
wrote a great article on that 301
million dollars now i hope it's a true
story i don't know if it is or not can i
maybe and then this might be the perfect
segue to roger stone i don't know if men
won i think maybe
um
being innocent until proved guilty one i
think you know
anti-cancer culture one i think
stopped judging uh
pre-judging uh anything before you the
facts come out one
um
everyone basically you know did you see
that what disney we could go on
valuetainment disney basically gave an
apology like we basically came down on
one down on bended knee and said our bat
mia culpa over here because they
much like the kanto culture warriors out
there were quick to dismiss him and now
you know the reason they're offering him
301 million it's because he said i would
never play this again even if they paid
me 300 million well you know
here's a little 301 million there for
you buddy um but
i mean maybe you want to weigh in on
what it feels like to do that i think i
agree with your analysis uh uh you know
first of all it was epically
entertaining so you had to every night
go see what was the latest in the dream
yeah um but i think truth won i think he
he acquitted himself well by presenting
his side of the case and doing it
compellingly
there was a i think a preconceived
judgment for her in the beginning what a
horrible toxic male he was what an
abusive individual he was
uh i was glad to see the way it came out
it did but roger you should believe all
women period yeah why don't you but yeah
right but but what you so you're being
sarcastic no well i'm i'm not being
sarcastic but you're being sarcastic and
you're saying this has nothing to do
with men of course it has something to
do with that but there's it's more than
men
i said yesterday i'm glad we're
transitioning away from guilty until
proven innocent instead of innocent
until proven guilty i get that but the
fact that you threw that sarcastic
comment at the end
means men get destroyed when it comes
down to this topic and it's good to see
men like him stand up if you screwed up
you deserve to you know whatever you're
getting if you didn't stand up boom
we're seeing progress so america is
simply getting sick of it the more and
more politics is getting involved
they're just getting sick of it saying
listen let me be able to give my opinion
without getting destroyed my career just
because i disagree with you which is
good to see that i'm but we'll go into
that clarence thomas what happened with
that coach i made a couple comments
we'll go into that uh but okay last one
i want to read because you brought up
guns i was going to read this before we
get into it so
uh congress passes most significant gun
reform bill in decades sends it to biden
cnbc story scrambling to respond to a
recent
uh spate a spat of bloody gun massacres
u.s lawmakers passed the most
significant federal gun restrictions in
decades on friday following years of
false starts and failures to tighten gun
laws following senate passage
late thursday the house passed a
bipartisan bill that takes steps to
restrict gun access to younger buyers
domestic violence offenders and others
who could pose a risk to their
communities the bipartisan saver
communities act also was would fund the
school safety and mental health programs
the house approved it by 243 to 193 and
193 as 14 republicans joined all
democrats the legislation says to
president biden who's expected to
quickly sign it into law is this
progress
i i think that the the passing of these
laws
attacking not the problem but the
popularity of the shock of this thing
you have
securing schools
that's a no-brainer we should have been
doing that
for the last 20 years my daughter is a
schoolteacher
i have done the security survey pro bono
for every school that she ever worked or
led
um and and they're buttoned down and you
have police officers
um
it's just
we're fighting
a political battle where it should be a
moral battle in my in my opinion
we have the right to defend ourselves
i believe that investing in mental
health i think that that's a very
important one what does that mean though
so that we're investing in mental health
unpacking we have we have to
keep is the uh see something say
something concept translate it into this
uh i don't remember where the place was
but the uh the second the last uh
incident
that we had the the um the perpetrator
he went to school for a whole week
wearing a hazmat suit
does i mean is that a normal behavior or
is that
you should you not look into a pattern
of behavior it's a thin line because you
also have what you just said which i
totally agree with
you're innocent until proven guilty
um
so
what do you think roger i'm afraid that
as he said earlier i'm not sure any of
those things are going to change
anything criminals will always find guns
absolutely and it is the cities with the
most restrictive gun policies in the
country where gun violence is is the
greatest in the case of the parkland
shooter
there were no less than seven calls to
this guy's house that never seemed to
get over to the fbi
uh he had been baker acted he'd been
taken involuntarily
they gave him psychotropic drops drugs
they put him back out on the street and
he killed people so i i agree with he
said i think there has to be a greater
emphasis on mental health guns don't
kill people people kill people criminals
miss credence will always get their
hands on guns what does that friend says
always say about uh gangsters and and uh
what just happened in the audio yeah
exactly what he just said the fact that
they'll they'll get their hands on guns
but but but you know like the left and
the right has
bullet points of three things that
everybody says and everybody keeps
saying it invest into mental health okay
i've heard a billion people saying
that's into mental health you know do
this do that the other day we were
talking with michael francis and we said
even if they raise
the uh what do you call it age limit 18
to 21 even if they make this even if
they do that even if they do this
ninety percent of the would he call it
uh mass shootings would have been
prevented even if they do that it would
have been prevented because they still
got some of them their guns that got it
illegally or some of them that got it
even the kid who got it he wasn't on any
kind of medication that's anxiety
medication or anything like that so
how much of that is
you know deeper that's going on within
america's values and principles and
morals
how much of that is the amount of drugs
that's in the hands of kids with big
pharma advertising the solution being
take this medicine take this medicine
take this medicine how much of it is the
video games how much of it is us
watching on tv
that over and over and over again they
keep turning these guys that are doing
mass shootings into heroes and we keep
talking about them
there has to be something because even
this strategy on what they're going to
be doing
90 something percent of them would have
been prevented
so does anybody really know the solution
or is it just pure political game that
both sides are playing
what do you think
there's no question that um had the
police officers either in texas or in
parkland done their jobs
that those mass shootings could have
been prevented ironically here in
parkland the officer in charge of school
security trained others in crisis
management uh but then when the time
came he stepped down he didn't do his
job so how do you so so think about that
so he did the training
and when it came down to it still didn't
do it he froze he froze so so again so
then what is the solution because
if we say we need more training
okay we did and even the training that
was done it still didn't happen
so does anybody really have the solution
that's going to help address this it's a
company it has to be a combination of
things
buttoning down the schools
is something that it's a reality
you cannot in good conscience bring
children and put them into that
environment unless you're able to
protect them
but one thing that we haven't talked
about here is how many people how many
police officers feel empowered
under this administration under this
current culture
where they're being defunded it you know
you're they're always guilty until
proving innocent if at all possible uh
don't get me wrong i've been in harm's
way more than once
so i know what it is to go to a door and
go
but i've gone through the door and that
was their job to do
but again
there's not a hundred percent fixed for
any of this it's five percent here
five percent mental health get buttoned
down the schools better training for the
police but also consequences there's got
to be consequences these police officers
that did not go in there
should be kicked out of the force
because if you are in an airborne unit
in the military and you decide not to
jump on a combat
guess what
you're going to jail so it it
we need to you know make them
accountable for for that mistake you
know what i would love here's what i
would love if a if a actuary if a bi is
listening to this if a business analyst
is listening to this if a guy that
studies statistics can listen to this
take time and make this video this video
can actually happen take all the mass
shootings of the last five ten years
okay
create the profile of everybody uh that
did the mass shooting
put their age how they got their weapon
if they were on medication their
background put it all at the top and
filter it out and then take the new
policies and changes that's coming up
and then read out the ones that could
have been prevented and green out that
the ones that would have happened no
matter what right and kind of go through
it and break down in a video what that
percentage comes down to because i think
the way they're going they're just
playing politics and the american people
are like oh awesome we passed something
yeah it really didn't do anything no no
but we did pass something no really
didn't do anything i think we need data
and we need somebody to analyze this
like a statistician somebody needs to do
that then we can say kind of like where
i'm going with this is moneyball you
know how in moneyball where the guy
comes out and he says look the only stat
that matters is what on base percentage
you don't win with home runs you don't
win well you won with unbased percentage
that's the guy that we need to bring
okay great then we bring him in then
they open you they interviewed that guy
multiple multiple people i love that guy
so i think a money ball concept
needs to be applied to
this for us to figure out what stat
matters the most
i don't think we're doing that that's
why i don't think we're doing i think
we're just kind of all talking and
but
i'm sorry i would add one extra tick on
there what's that and you touched on it
roger a little earlier on
make a study of how many of the criminal
acts
with a weapon
that weapon was a legally obtained
weapon and in the hands of a legal carry
individual
that's a huge statistic
when people quote
gun violence you have to at least be
able to focus on where is the base of
that violence and it is the criminal
world
and
do they don't have prosecution the
police can't can't barely do the job as
it is
um
it is that would be i would love to add
that to your your ticket for that i mean
i mean i get it that we have a campaign
you know where the campaign the manager
may say listen when it comes down to gun
violence here's the three points that
you have to hit boom boom boom that's
what you got to go and then just know
these 22 statistics see which one of
these you can remember and recite but
that's where you got to go but that's
marketing that's not we're not really
it's not really a solution we're just
marketing and saying hey if they ask you
to say that i'd love to have somebody
comes out and actually breaks this down
and say here's what it would have
changed and not changed i don't know
well you're going to have that
opportunity we've now passed these laws
there'll be an election in two years
let's watch the cro violent crime
statistics for those two years and see
if they really change anything well no
there's going to be an election in
five months i understand that's probably
not in all fairness and not enough time
so let these policies be in place
they're going to be in place because i
don't see them being repealed
and you'll know in two years whether
they've made a meaningful change what
needs to happen almost immediately
is
bail reform because right now we have a
situation in almost every major city in
the country which they've done away with
bail uh and criminals recidivist
criminals are right back out on the
street many of them to hurt people again
particularly new york city and new york
so uh
there's uh i think something that has to
be reformed almost immediately so you
know what i also would want to know out
of all these guys that did a mass
shooting what percentage is alive
what percentage is on the street what
percentages say is serving a life
sentence how bad was the
what do you call it uh the price that
they paid for it is it purely all about
a uh uh uh what do you call a celebrity
you know the 15 uh
minutes of fame is that really what it
was all about has somebody taken all of
these guys and gone and done a document
documentary to interview every one of
these guys to come up with an analysis
to say this is the similarity we know
which job is that like this yeah
no no i don't think they're gonna so
even to pull up to see out of all these
mass shooting guys that how many of them
were from a single parent how many of
them had a father i want all of those
statistics to see what commonality do we
see
you can pull up that data then we say
listen
these three that you guys keep talking
about would only say five percent but
these two would have eliminated 42 let's
address these two we're not we're just
winging it it's just like is this
something
a a public
company or a you know a government
agency would do or
if i was a governor if i was a governor
of a state or if i was a president
i would go hire
10 engineers okay from silicon valley
and i would bring them from silicon
valley from the best places in the world
okay and i would bring them that
politically i would interview them to
make sure they're kind of like you know
how you're you hire a jury and you make
sure how they feel politically they're
not linked or any way they don't have an
opinion about the guy i would bring in
okay you guys are neutral perfect here's
three hundred thousand dollars per year
what's ten times three hundred thousand
dollars nothing chump change i want you
to pull up every data every stat every
everything you can
and give us the exact reason why this is
taking place if if the stats are out
there you can pull it up from the fbi we
can find that exactly this is not going
to cost that much money to do it's three
million dollars maybe a 10 million
dollar project hired the best analyst
guys data guys put them in the room pull
up all the data within 30 60 90 days we
can figure this thing out but here's the
problem with the data so the other day
you said we used this story there were
200 what does that sound by the way keep
hearing a sound like
oh yeah i don't know sorry so there were
226 mass shootings in the united states
through whatever it was six months uh do
you know what qualifies as a mass
shooting
it's four people if over four people
were shot not killed were shot that
qualifies as a mass shooting where do
you think the majority of that comes
from gang violence the majority of mass
shootings in the united states aren't
kids going and shooting up schools it's
not i mean it's it's it's gang violence
one and most of the again we we cover
this most of the mass shootings happen
with a pistol not an assault rifle or a
rifle by the way all of that is part of
the data yes but i think the data can be
skewed but two it's it's
people don't want to address first of
all mass shootings
as they stand where it's gang violence
as opposed to mass shootings of
like you say mentally deranged people
walking in shooting people and those
kinds of things so again i think when we
say use the data again we have to
clarify what data are we using but tyler
that's also
in the insurance industry
actuaries actually do that as well they
break down by age where you realize you
know when we get table d rating on most
of the people that are table d are 55
and up or if i would live in this [ __ ]
place and a lot of them are from this
you can track nationality you can track
sex you can track married you can track
the you can track any of that stuff but
with what you just said i would add that
to the data as well yeah i would and i
would say the mass shooting you know
what we would put on the mass shooting
how many people were involved this one's
four well 42 percent of them are only
four okay let's put that in this
category by itself ten percent is ten or
more let's put that in the category by
itself i don't think this is that
complicated i don't know if they want to
find the answer
i don't know if they well no because
they want to manipulate it they want to
tell you that there's 120 it's going to
take 10 million but you just gave 40
billion to ukraine it would take you 10
million bucks to figure this thing out
put people in the room get it funded
within a three-month period you get some
answers but we haven't done that i don't
know why we haven't done that well let
me add on to what tyler's saying because
you do bring up a good point if you saw
on the headlines
four people shot in the streets of
chicago you're like alright cool next
story move on with life we're so
desensitized to these types of stories
where america is at where most americans
are yearning are when we see dead
six-year-olds
innocent dead six-year-olds in a
classroom
there's i don't care if you're on the
left on the right we are disgusted by
this and that's what is grabbing the
headlines and that's what why literally
congress finally effing did something
and i think it's about time whether it's
optics whether it's the sizzle or the
stake remains to be seen like roger said
we'll find out in two years if they've
done anything but we're [ __ ] sick of
it we're sick of dead kids in classrooms
we're not sick of what tyler's basically
talking about which is probably 90 plus
percent of the mass murderers is just
five people got shot on it's going to
happen on july 4th weekend you can book
it down right now across america someone
in st louis shot five people whatever
next story keep it moving we are sick of
the classroom [ __ ] though
my point on this by the way um
people have to take emotions out of
these kind of decisions that's why i
like your
document and dissect
because if you look at forget the four
people that get shot in new york or
whatever that that doesn't count but
school's best shootings
in the last five years give me those
numbers
that happens in new york in three months
actually probably happens in new york in
two weeks you're saying just in the
streets just in the streets just on the
street you know we cannot focus on the
problem emotionally
yes i personally you know i cannot if i
was in that school i would have had to
go in i couldn't live with myself
i could not live with myself if i didn't
go in there and try to help him out
but
that is still a minority and it is it is
very serious and use that tipping point
to make things
make sense and i i think that approach
of statistics not skewed the statistics
uh i think would help create a real plan
that they could implement so
i run one too many companies to do this
i would have taken i would have done
this myself as a project just to turn it
into a documentary through 60 even a 70
minute 75 minute documentary just to go
out there and say let me tell you how
what uh approach we took this here's a
problem here's the approach we took we
wanted to find out what's going on this
is the data we came up with okay and we
brought five people from the left
five people from the right five people
in the middle they all have strong
opinions we all want to find out we're
all open to finding out what's going on
what the solution is here's what we're
proposing to the world i would take that
approach anyways i hope somebody does it
because i think it's that important of
an issue that we need to invest that
money into doing this if i have to
choose between spending 40 billion
dollars into ukraine and 40 billion
dollars into finding out why this is
happening in our schools in america what
do you think we're doing with that 40
billion
it's it's a lot better 40 billion
spending to finding out why this is
happening to our kids
rather than why this is happening
nothing wrong with me listen i'm don't
want to see anything happen to anybody
but this is our homeland if this is
where we live and you're proud of where
you are let's invest the money into
those resources into uh our country
instead of others okay so next
um
is this did you
have anything to say about this you know
when you heard it were you like
you know the the paranoid side come out
to say why did he just make that comment
when um
biden went out there what page is this
on let me find this page six
um
so uh president biden says u.s needs
more funding for the next pandemic
reuters june 21st president joe biden
said on tuesday united states has enough
coveted funding to get through at least
this year but it needs more money to
plan for the next pandemic we need more
money to plan for the next pandemic
there's going to be another pandemic we
have to think ahead biden said in
remarks at the white house to mark
availability of vaccines for young
children which he said we are the first
country
in the world to have vaccines for
kids under the age of six months which
he celebrated and the commentary if you
read it it's actually
95 of people who commented on it was
negative but
are you reading into this comment or is
it just no we do need to prepare for the
next first of all how does he know we're
going to have another pandemic number
one number two i'm not
one who believes that the covid19
vaccination is necessarily safe nor
effective but i also believe that if you
decide you want to take it that's fine
that's up to you nobody should be
required to take it i believe in health
freedom but i also wonder whether there
is a political motivation in other words
if you wanted to say for example that
going to the polls was too dangerous
because of a pandemic and that all
voting should be done by mail-in ballot
i think that's an open invitation for
voter fraud
good point
any thoughts on your end or no no you
know the one that i do uh have a comment
on because both of you have used the
term a couple of times of giving money
to ukraine i i take a slightly different
uh ulterior motive for this and that
comes because of my background
russia second only to china is a problem
that we have had since 1917 and we will
continue to have as long as they're in
power
and if you look at history
uh afghanistan war we helping the
afghanis and i know that with 2020
hindsight we go gee we should have taken
the missiles back before we left
but
the ukraine can be the downfall
of what the soviet union is trying to
become
because when the russian body bags start
going back home
and let me tell you something one the
the us has been helping the ukraine's
iranians since 2015.
they did not learn how to fight and how
to run intelligence networks in the last
three months
because there has been a
big shift from fighting wars to taking
steps to prevent wars
and the only way you can do that is
working with individuals in countries
that are allies
fortifying them and if there's an issue
let them fight that fight and you
support it but i i am all for for uh
keeping ukraine as that thorn in the
side of the russians besides the
humanitarian part and the atrocities are
being committed this is where we're
going to have to disagree
we signed a treaty in 1994 promising not
to have
uh ukraine join nato which is defined as
putting missiles aimed at russia
in nato
we're now seeking to do that this is not
different than 1962 when the russians
put missiles in cuba and president
kennedy objected
and that was resolved thank god
diplomatically
we do have bio-weapons labs uh in
ukraine the silos are actually built we
haven't just dropped the missiles in i
think this could have been resolved
diplomatically had ukrainians not agreed
to join nato which is defined as putting
western missiles in their country uh the
idea that putin
who's not a good guy i want to be very
clear i mean my family were rushing down
mowed down by russian tanks in budapest
i have no truck for the russians he's a
thug
but at the same time the idea that he
just wants to occupy ukraine he can't
even afford that his economy is a basket
case so uh this is going to be a costly
war for him
but i think it could have been resolved
short of the carnage we see today i
don't disagree with that but the thing
that that ship has sailed we are at war
and if you're going to get any silver
lining out of this is let's really
button that up you know if the argument
that putin uses about ukraine being a
threat to them
well why are we doing something against
cuba
cuba is the the cancer of latin america
nicaragua venezuela
colombia now
all these are are funded and influenced
and led there are more intel officers
from the cuban service
in those kind of countries
propping them up
didn't didn't colombia just get the
first socialist uh
venezuela he was actually the uh a
former senior
uh terrorist
part of the guerrilla camp he was one of
the commanders of gorilla camps but you
have to you have to wonder why the u.s
senate
and the one hand votes to give 40
million dollars in aid mostly military
lethal aids supposedly to ukraine but
then they vote down a motion to have an
inspector general track where that
money's going why wouldn't you want to
know where that money's going
it makes no sense to me yes somebody
just commented inception child said
uh uh what will it take to put putin on
a terrorist list like biden like bin
laden was or is he a terrorist only if
he attacks america so do you see
putin as somebody that should be on that
list or no he shouldn't be on that list
well you know he
he should for different reasons but you
got to understand that what why are we
surprised at what putin is doing the
kind of person he is he's not the
anomaly in in in russian and soviet
government
if you go back to stalin and khrushchev
and everybody in between the majority of
those the leaders of soviet union and
now russia
are of that criminal bet you know they
have that mentality uh
uh the oligarchs that you know you've
got a hundred billionaires in russia
that are bleeding money
uh those things all these things made
you know bad for for russia
but he should that that that would be
another nail on his coffin declaring him
that because he is
he is responsible for the acts that the
military is committing in ukraine
would he be uh held accountable for war
crimes is that what you're saying
absolutely let me ask you to follow up
on that rick you basically have said
that russians and communists are
expansionists right and then you
followed up and you said
um you know regarding putin's goals and
i want to ask you about putin's goals
you said that there a terminology i used
to use was creeping normalcy which is
basically you take a piece you wait for
a little bit
and then um you know kind of wait for
things to simmer down again and then
boom you attack again so what do you
think putin's goals are
he said it when he first took power i
will reconstitute
the soviet union to his previous glory
um
that's a clue right there
how do you create the soviet union again
you take over romania you take over
georgia you attack
you know take over the ukraine they are
inspectionistic
i don't think the cha the uh the um the
russians are creeping normalcy types
they're they're too blunt they're too
blunt over that
koreans and asian
chinese are extremely good at that
that creeping normalcy and
where whereas we have barely three year
plans because of the fourth year the
president has to start focusing on the
re-election
the chinese or the russians don't have
that problem they can have a 50-year
plan a 100-year plan and you tweak it
according to what it is but the the end
goal is still the same our end goal as
america should be to remain a republic
their goal is to world domination
when you say they who do you mean the
russians and the chinese do you agree
we should stop pretending the ukrainians
are uh democracy they're not democracy
they're not after the last election uh
zelen
uh arrested the guy who ran second
closed down and arrested all the leaders
of the opposition party and closed down
the three tv stations that supported his
opponent this is not a democracy it's an
epically corrupt government uh i'd like
to know where the money's going zlinski
has it by the way a beautiful 3.5
million condominium right here in miami
beach how did he get that he's an actor
he's uh he was an actor prior to his
public service so i think it's an
epically uh corrupt government uh and i
i just don't think the issues
uh that are being used to rationalize
the war
are are accurate i think this could have
been resolved
by our simply agreeing to honor our
commitment 94 not to put missiles into
into ukraine well roger you know how
many
uh wealthy russian oligarch types have
condos and sunny isles not too far from
here they all do maybe they're not in
government service though
and i'm not and by the way i'm not uh
i'm not defending the russians i just
would like to see
us not have a war i'm not i'm not for
this becoming uh being conflagrated into
world war three let me ask you we um we
recently had on your old buddy paul
manafort who was very outspoken on what
we should do with ukraine do you do you
guys are you guys still in touch do you
guys have similar opinions on this
matter he knows far more about the area
than it is right because he's worked
there i never worked there and i'm not
as familiar with the geopolitics of it
as he is
um i only you know
my views are formed by what i read so i
can't i can either first i didn't see
your show so i never agree or disagree
we're in touch and we're certainly
friendly
we've had a similar experience shall we
say well you guys used to have a a
lobbyist firm yes called uh what black
man of fortune black manafort stone 30
years ago yeah exactly and um
he was very outspoken on ukraine he was
actually very informed um so is that
someone you consult with on ukraine
matters or are you guys still friends
first of all he worked for the
ukrainians
20 years after that firm was dissolved
so i've never i i was not involved in
any of that and i didn't have an
international practice um we haven't
talked about that this particular issue
our conversation's more about how my
wife's doing how his wife's doing i mean
his wife has had some health problems my
wife has had some health problems so um
no we have a cordial relationship we're
still friends good to hear well
but let's let's stay on this topic let's
stay on this topic because we kind of
this led into uh the the challenges with
russia so three topics i'll
read all together and then i want to
process all of it together on how
bad things are in russia you see one
side where you hear the approval rating
of putin is what the highest it's ever
been it's at the what was the number we
were looking at tyler 83 something like
that something like that that's high but
at the same time russia sinks into
historic default
as sanctions muddy next steps tougher
western sanctions that shut down payment
routes to overseas creditors for months
russia had found pads
around the penalties imposed after uh
the kremlin's invasion of ukraine but at
the end of the day on sunday the grace
period on about 100 million dollars of a
trapped interest payment due may 27
expired a deadline considered as an
event of default
if missed this is a bloomberg story then
there was a g7 story with g7 nations to
announce import ban on russian gold that
moscow sanctions widen
uh the leaders of g7 nation will
announce that on uh ban for russian gold
imports uh on unprovoked invasion of
ukraine etc etc so the move would add to
a series of punitive penalties imposed
by the west on russia since
its onslaught of ukraine on february
24th and last but not least which
uh
you know when when a
commentator says this it is what it is
when a writer says it it is what it is
when a leader of a superpower says this
you have to actually
you know consider what he's saying
vladimir putin ally warns london
will bomb will be bombed first if world
war three were to break out it's one of
his allies that says this
uh london will be the first strategic
nato target to hit
by russian missiles should a third world
war erupt a close ally vladimir putin
has claimed speaking on the russian
state tv
andre
guroloyov on nmp who sits on moscow
defense committee described how possible
full-scale invasion nato ballistic
baltic state members would work
he a former military commander member of
the pro-putin united russia party said
will destroy the entire group of the
enemy space
satellites during the first air
operation
no one will care if they are american or
british we would see them all as nato
second
will migrate the entire system of
anti-missile defense everywhere in a
hundred percent
third we'll certainly won't start
from warsaw paris or berlin the first to
be hit will be london
how much credence should we give to this
i i think that's political parking uh
look at their the russian army's
performance in ukraine
they've had their asses handed to them
these they were bringing in these young
untrained
well you know not well prepared
individuals and it's been a massacre you
know the might of the of the soviet
union is part of the illusion just like
the statistics of putin's popularity
when you control the media look what's
happening in this country when you
control the media you control the minds
of a lot of people or at least what
you're projecting out there
so what are you saying
i in my particular case i'm a cuban-born
i lived under communism i saw what
communism did to my country i fought it
in nicaragua i fought
i fought it in five different
incarnations
so i am a rabbit
anti-communist
and if we have an opportunity
to
really hurt the russians right now i
think that it's worth the money i agree
that ukraine is not the cleanest slate
well neither was afghanistan new was
iraq how many all the wars that we have
spent and by the way guys
both my kids are military
one of them has two combat tours and i
have been in harm's way so this is this
is all like it should be i think a
personal thing
i saw what communism is i know that it
is they have the goal of destroying this
country from within
from within they don't need to attack us
they're attacking us through the media
and all this undermining that they're
doing let me ask you what do you think
about yuri besmanov
i don't know okay because if you're
going that angle maybe i thought you
were going that angle go ahead roger
what do you think well i certainly share
his anti-communism uh but the chinese
communists are a far bigger threat to
our absolutely uh than the russians and
the one thing the ukraine conflict has
done is to push the russians and the
chinese together
they have had a historical distrust of
each other they share a common border
richard nixon got us a strategic arms
limitation agreement out of the russians
by playing them off against the chinese
so but uh to the extent that uh
that the russians have economic problems
they have a very wealthy neighbor
willing to prop them up and they can
deng xiaoping keeps sending that signal
so uh i also don't think that the war is
going swimmingly for the ukraines
ukrainians i think we're getting a lot
of war propaganda and it appears to me
that there are atrocities on both sides
the azoff brigade
he's got all wars in all wars well and
that's the most important part right
there is what rogers has said is that
russia's economy is smaller than south
korea's and and to date this is reuters
june 27th uh the ruble is still the
strong the world's strongest uh currency
against the dollar the russian economy
has not tanked like people expected it
to it's still smaller than south korea
but
what roger said we're pushing vladimir
putin into the arms of xi jinping xi
jinping is the threat we're sending 50
billion to ukraine we're sending missile
systems we're sending 100 000 troops
we're not going to be able to defend
ourselves in a couple months with the
strongest nuclear power on the face of
the earth why are we worried about
russia yes i agree with an
anti-communist stance but again russia
isn't what we should be worried about
what happens three steps down the road
when china makes a move on taiwan when
china eventually makes a move on japan
they're building islands in the south
china china sea to use as airports like
they're they're making serious moves and
we're off concerned with vladimir putin
who's i mean he's a he's a bully he's
nothing more than a bully but when you
when you when you remove the sanctions
against the iranians you're sending a
signal to the chinese that we won't
stand up
so i mean when when your foreign policy
exudes weakness it's an open invitation
for the chinese to move on taiwan it's
it's an invitation for the world i mean
you've heard the comparison of biden
with uh
um um jimmy carter jimmy carter uh jimmy
carter was at least a very decent moral
man and not a corrupt man he was a very
naive man
but what happened as soon as he took
over
russia takes over afghanistan
the iranian hostage crisis we had people
there for 444 days
give away the panel pad on my canal
which is a huge strategic mistake
but what happened when reagan came in
as soon as he swore in
the hostages were released
so i i totally agree with you we need to
have leadership and that was one of the
beauties about trump
you don't mess with trump
because he is going to come at you
whether it's verbally physically or
militarily he is going to come out
you know this meeting for you and i to
be introduced to each other was set up
by carter
i don't know if you know that or not
jimmy carter
set up this meeting for you and i to
meet each other
because you're here in america
because of carter i'm here in america
from iran because of carter so thank you
jimmy for introducing me to rick
and i would have recruited you for the
agency 20 years ago if i would have come
across you and then you could have
winked to your dad you know and then
a little peanut farmer would have
brought you two guys together going back
to what you guys were saying so
this is a concern i have and i'm curious
to know if you feel the same way as well
are are the the current actions we're
taking
causing china and russia to get closer
than they were pre to the ukraine russia
war
there's every evidence that that is the
case yeah absolutely so but in the
meantime
the chinese are systematically buying up
half of the country the world real
estate farmland rangelands across the
united states i mean there's 300 000
acres in oklahoma alone statistic i read
yesterday that's phenomenal uh they're
buying control of minerals almost all
naturally all over the country
everywhere across the globe um they are
a far greater threat
to us than the russians i i totally
agree i mean look what happened when
afghanistan the taliban declared
themselves the legal government of of
afghani of the country china was the
first one to recognize them
why because a lot of those minerals that
you just alluded to are in the in in the
underlands of of afghanistan
and to go back to a question you asked
earlier in all honesty
biden's decision to withdraw our troops
from afghanistan was not the wrong
decision trump had been withdrawing our
troops it how he did it was not it was
how he did it not using our drones not
using our technology to pin down the
taliban while we were about to cover our
back while we were leaving uh and the
decision not to remove our equipment or
destroy it which was an option before we
left well
this is great commentary on this topic
uh i want us to go to our last topic
before we finish the podcast we'll spend
the last 20 minutes on this topic here
and that's clarence thomas roe v wade
and all the
other stories that come with it so
uh biden and other critics fear thomas's
extreme possession
uh position on contraception okay if you
go to page three
uh uh let me read the story here in an
opinion concurring with his conservative
colleagues on the supreme court to
overturn the fundamental right on
abortion justice clarence thomas wrote
on friday that striking down roe v wade
should also open up
the high court to review other
precedents that may be deemed
demonstrably erroneous amongst these
thomas wrote was the right for married
couples to buy and use contraception
without government restriction
from the landmark 1965 ruling in
griswold versus connecticut in future
cases we should reconsider all of this
court sub substantive
due process precedents including
griswold lawrence and others thomas
wrote on page 119 of the opinion in
dobbs versus jackson women's health also
referring to the ruling that legalize
same-sex marriage relationships
respectively because any substantive due
process decision is demonstrably
erroneous we have a duty to correct the
error establishing those precedents
thomas added after overruling these
demonstral erroneous decisions the
question would remain
whether other constitutional provisions
guaranteed the myriad rights that our
substantive due process cases have
generated so obviously we know what's
happened the last week since this was
announced riots are everywhere
protesting is going on everywhere people
are
going uh uh berserk with this decision
that's been made
um
how much more you think this is gonna
continue
and how far along you think clarence
thomas is going to know knowing that
they have an advantage right now being
6-3
well we can't assume that there's a 6-3
majority for everything that won justice
sure so i i i was surprised that roe v
wade was repealed to be honest with you
so i didn't hand and i don't see those
things happen but i of course could be
wrong
uh the idea of course that
uh that
saying the state should regulate
abortion is extreme no the idea of
killing a fetus after there's a
heartbeat that's extreme to me so uh
this i think what we've done here is go
back to democracy in its purest form i
mean abortion is going to be legal
and in the states where it is legal that
will be because the voters there want it
to be legal if they don't like vote
abortion restriction or they want more
restrictions the voters have the
opportunity to vote in people who will
give them that but the idea that
abortion will be unavailable
that's not accurate
you know it's a very personal item for
me because my youngest oldest son his
wife is pregnant with the baby she's
four months old
and
i saw the sonograms and the heartbeat of
that kid
in less than two months
um it is murder
um
if a woman is raped or if or giving
birth to a child is going to cause her
to die or for whatever reasons
then
i totally also agree that the states
like every
libertarian would
should be making the decisions for the
people and the voters the one that does
it
um but i would go as far as if if you
in in a state where it's not legal
you
do abortions that should be murder
the minute there's a heartbeat as far as
i'm concerned you're killing something
and it's very easy to say i'm going to
have an abortion
and you don't see what's going on but
what would the what would 99 of the
women do if they say okay abortions from
now on is we will reject the the fetus
and before it is dead you got to kill it
so there there's a there's a few
different areas to go with this here
right one is the pro choice pro-life
debate okay which that debates
being had 24 7 non-stop let's set that
aside i don't want us to go through that
debate because
we would need to have a panel with a
couple other ladies to comment as well
let's set that part aside okay
the the part that we were having this
debate in monaco was the following is
do i want that decision to be made by
the federal
by the state or permanently making it
illegal we got really three options if
we look at it right so
the federal government makes it illegal
to have an abortion in any state
let's say that's extreme right
or the federal government makes it legal
for anybody to have abortion in any
state let's say that's extreme to some
people right
uh
why do you think some people are having
a challenge with it being the state's
decision to do so is it because
in case if i live in a state where i do
want to have an abortion i don't have
the choice to do so i move to another
another state doesn't that sound like a
reasonable thing to do to leave it to
the states to make that decision what do
you think roger
that's why i agreed with this decision
the the decision will now go to the
states uh and the government that is
closest to the people always makes the
best decision if the people in texas
texas is now ill abortions illegal in
texas if the people of texas want to
change that they'll have ample
opportunity to do that
whereas abortion is readily available in
new york you could probably have it you
know in the in the late trimesters uh
the voters there could also change that
if they want to so i think this is
actually the the right solution if you
look at it from a public opinion point
of view
a slim majority of voters think that
abortion should be legal but they also
support a number of restrictions on it
they don't want it available on demand
at any time for any reason
the intensity on this issue
is on the extremes
uh just prior to row when people were
asked in a gallup poll what are the most
important issues facing the country four
percent said abortion rights four
percent
uh so i don't i don't believe this is
going to be the issue for november that
brings the democrats back and lets them
detract from gasps i don't think so no i
think in the end it'll end up being a
wash actually well let me give you some
stats
because a majority of americans do
disagree with this supreme court
decision can i throw some stats out
there if they understand it yeah
um
overall 56 percent of the american
people
disagree with this 40 support it four
percent are still somehow unsure
by party dem democrats 88
oppose this 10 support it
and the gop uh 77
support it
20 i'm sorry yes 77
support this ruling
20 oppose it independence and this is
what we always talk about this is the
people you got to pay attention to 53
oppose this so a slim majority 41
support by gender male 54
oppose this 43 support 53 of sorry 59
of females oppose this decision
and 38
support so
there's a uh
we could all you know four dudes sitting
around in a room we could all give our
opinions who was that pulled by i'm
curious this is on npr your favorite
people well that makes sense if it's npr
but go ahead but
the they're they're polling the american
people there though so are you saying
that that it's far i'm saying i can
write a poll make it say anything i want
by the way i word the questions okay i
may have seen well i think what's going
to happen i agree with you that the
economy is going to be the number one
issue in the midterms but
um this is going to be something that's
going to get the american women to the
poll i mean we said that soccer moms
control the votes that it was the
coveted moms
women are going to have a massive vote
right here here's some stats for you um
where is it here
78 of democrats say roe decision makes
them more likely to vote in the midterms
78 of democrats say they are now more
likely to vote in the in the midterms
because of this as opposed to 54 of gop
that's a 24 difference we talked about a
million americans now considering
becoming a republican versus a democrat
the number one issue for sure is the
economy but then you're gonna have
culture wars guns
abortions
immigration
uh this is no small thing women are
[ __ ] pissed okay and i don't have a
horse in this race i'm not a woman i got
a question i don't have any i i got a
question i got a question so
um
this this will be a strange metaphor to
make but to me it kind of makes sense
you know how we say
well you know we can make guns illegal
but the bad guy's always going to find
the guns okay where's the bad guy gonna
buy you the guns from probably from
another bad guy right let's just say if
that's the case okay
so in these states where they can't do
abortion
and they want to get an abortion and
they can't afford to go to another state
to get the abortion what do they do
is there going to be underground
abortion operations being started yes is
there going to be so there's going to be
a black market yeah so if there's a for
sure so if there's a black market for it
where is the protection
if that does happen
for the woman that's going to do it
whether you let her or not she's going
to go find somebody in the black market
let's call it a black mark in the states
that don't allow it
to go get it done
and maybe the black market is going to
be ran by people who have done abortions
professionally
at a clinic at you know because planned
parenthood essentially becomes a black
market in those states that don't allow
so maybe they start something on the
side and they do it for 250 or whatever
so they're going to provide some kind of
protection but the safety of insurance
will ensure so if somebody goes and does
an abortion at an illegal place in the
black market and something happens to
her health
will health insurance not come in and
protect them i don't think so because it
is an illegal behavior that's taking
place so that is a problem that those
states have to address now
uh i left my position in slightly a
different position to take with this i
i'm a stat guy right i like data because
data tells me a story so some are saying
clarence thomas
is saving more black lives than black
lives matter
because if you look at statistically in
the u.s population right u.s population
60 percent are white the u.s population
60 is white
blacks is 12.2 percent let me say that
one more time
five times more is the population of
whites versus blacks okay
meanwhile 37 of all abortions are black
women versus 33 of abortions are white
so even though whites are five times the
amount of blacks
the abortion for blacks is higher than
whites which is six times the amount of
abortions a you know
blacks get then why so some people say
well that's racist
well the racist in that topic can be
seen in two different ways because more
black kids
are being aborted then white kids are
being aborted so who is the racist
does that decrease the chances of more
blacks having a voice in the community
make a difference if we're getting five
times more to kids to be aborted and you
know back in the days this was a
conspiracy on the fact that they were
doing this because with the whole crowd
you know all the stories that was going
on this is a way to eliminate from
hey let's go out there and do this
because this can help us uh with the
amount of voice that they could have
there is that topic that's coming up as
well when you're looking at the stats in
regards to
what's going on with uh clarence thomas
but
if you if you break it down in the state
you're the governor
here's how the governor says look in our
state we don't want to do
abortions you don't like it guess what
if an if a governor really supports this
this is how the governor's approach
should be
we don't
but
there are 17 states you can go to where
you can get it
okay very simple go to the 17 states
okay
you know if somebody
protests and riots against somebody that
doesn't allow same-sex marriage guess
what that state governor can say
we don't
but there's these 17 states that you can
go to that does they support you go to
that state
so
now pat that's racist well let me tell
you what i did i'm in california and i'm
against the 13 and a half percent state
taxes then the gas taxes and this taxes
and regulation all this other stuff and
guess what governor newsom said
he said to me indirectly
well if you don't like it
there's these seven states that you
don't pay taxes and guess what i said i
said you know what i appreciate the
offer governor newsom i moved to texas i
lived in texas for five years and 18
months ago
we moved to florida right to be in a
state like this because i like the way
the governor handled it so my position
here to those that are losing their
minds is the following
the hypocrisy is when people are rioting
and protesting in states where abortion
hasn't changed california you're fine
you're fine protesting in your it's very
weird that you're protesting you're not
affected by this this is affected to
some other states that are doing it i
say oh i agree go and protest that's one
of the freedoms that we have in america
but just like a business owner can
choose to leave to another state because
they have low regulation and lower taxes
to allow them to hire more people you
also have the choice to move to a
different state that gives you those
freedoms to do whatever you want to do
with your body
is that uh uh discriminatory i don't
know i think you have a choice so if
you're in a state that does doesn't
allow you and that really infuriates you
you have two choices try to make the
change in that state which is kind of
what you were talking about right or
number two go move to a state that
allows you to do that you have a choice
it's america you're not
and you now have major employers saying
that they will pay for the travel now
now are they really saying well paying
for maternity leave is a lot more
expensive than paying for an abortion
uh but
first of all i would say two things
pulling any question in the eye of the
storm is very difficult you're gonna get
you're gonna get a skewed result do you
agree with the decision that that
implies people know what the decision
means many of my friends said abortion
is now illegal everywhere well that's
not what this decision says so
what this looks like in three months
could be very different than what it
looks like today depends on it depends
on
public understanding of the issue which
i'm not sure is there today i like what
you said um polling in the eye of the
storm was is what how'd you describe it
yes exactly it's what
well whenever you try to take a survey
in the middle of a crisis exactly
the emotions play a huge role right
until things settle down and public
opinions are more set
uh when you're in the middle of the
controversy is not the time to measure
the impact of well that's the time that
people are gonna want you're going to
know the sentiment of the country
well yeah but even though recognizing it
may be temporary well let me say one
thing
the
as always just like in the economy just
everything with kovid
who's going to get hurt the most the
poor
like the poor don't have the luxury of
just moving to another state or having
their amazing fortune 500 corporation
pay for their abortion who says who says
who says i was poor we moved to america
immigrants come to america they're rich
i'm sorry do immigrants who come to
america are rich immigrants poor
immigrants i'm talking about state to
state though no but that's even easier
it's easier to go to another state than
to come to a country
people are going to go move to another
state maybe they want to get on the menu
are
they don't have to move they just have
to go there for the procedure yeah you
you so if you're in the if you're in the
in the belly of texas and you gotta how
what's the closest state to texas that
you can go get an abortion california
okay so how long is that going to take i
mean i'm just saying it's not it's not
as easy
as
all right no
no but i tell you i tell you when we
when i was in california and i was broke
guess where i went to a dentist
where where mexico mexico jesus
yes okay you know what the prices of
mexico compared to what it is in
california i would drive five and a half
hours to go to tj to see my dentist that
didn't speak english
i went there and he got it done and it
was good enough your beautiful teeth the
point i'm trying to make you i was poor
i was 49k in debt and i had barely 500
bucks in a bank i had no money but i'm
like listen my teeth are killing me i
can't even stay so
i get what you're saying on the fact
that you have the choice to go to
another state look just like the rest of
us move if you don't
like where you're living at and there 40
million immigrants
are in america
where do they leave if the situation was
so great they would have never left they
left because they were not happy with
something if you're not happy
living in a state that's red or purple
and is disagreeing with your views i
highly recommend you move to oregon move
to california move to new york move to
chicago it's more of people that agree
with you look the story of ayn rand with
atlas shrugged what is the story you
know the story is there's a city that
you go to where you're around
like-minded people if you want to be
around like-minded people and you afford
this
or any of this stuff there's plenty of
states for you okay
we came on i never said hey guys we
should consider moving to oregon did i
did you ever hear me say oregon no thank
you did i ever say or florida illinois i
said a couple states and we came here
can i can i make one quick point about
our friend clarence thomas yes uh this
man does not represent america okay and
i'll tell you why and this is not my
opinion but i went on to axios are they
a trustworthy source anyone maybe
but they did a um
they basically judge the the political
leanings of the supreme court and on the
supreme court you have someone that's on
the very far far left sotomayor and
someone who is on the extreme right
clarence thomas and they are both on
they are when you talk about the far
left and the far right have the loudest
voices that's them so remove them
basically they have a plus one plus two
plus three right
if you're plus three you're very extreme
on the right that's where clarence
thomas is
sotomayor is plus three on the left
these are very extreme liberal and
conservative voices that's not where
america is you know where america is
everyone's going crazy over gorsuch
everyone's going crazy over amy comey
barrett everyone's going crazy over uh
kavanaugh right but they're just plus
ones they're right where john roberts is
they're not extremists okay and just on
the left you have kagan
and uh breyer this is where america is
so
five out of the seven justices are what
i would say represent most americans
clarence thomas is an extremist whether
you agree with him or not he is
you talk about it
also an extremist that's exactly what i
said yeah she's extremely on the left
that's true but they were both appointed
supreme court by duly elected presidents
of different parties
uh and we're supposed to believe in the
rule of law they're the justices whether
you like it i'm not saying that they
should be you know unhinged or taken off
the court i'm just saying clarence
thomas's opinions are not what 90 of
americans agree with he is an extremist
just like she is
okay but you also this is a supreme
court that upheld obamacare for example
uh and those republicans all swung for
that not him though not well i
understand that but he's there for life
let me let me let me let me say
something here that we all have learned
the last six years okay this is what
we've all learned
to flip three seeds
may be
the biggest milestone
if you can be a two-term president and
flip no seats or be a one-term president
and flip three seats
10 out of 10 times any party left or
right would take
a one-term president who flips three
seats that may be the biggest milestone
any president's ever done in mankind to
favor their party i'm talking about
trump oh mike well you remember his
quote what's that whether you love me or
hate me you gotta vote for me because of
the supreme court yeah remember he came
out and said that he was forced he was
up front about what he was going to do
it was interesting that in his comments
when biden sailed the decision the court
he attacked the three justices appointed
by trump he didn't mention the two
appointed by bush who voted the same way
didn't even mention them yeah and and by
the way if you go back and you study
clarence thomas's history linked to
biden your opinion about clarence thomas
would be very different if you actually
go back and see what this guy's done in
his life
he's got one of the best resumes on what
he's doing i don't know especially where
he came from i mean he he was raised by
his grandfather in literal poverty he
couldn't even speak english let me tell
you something i give two shits about
because i don't have an opinion on him
i'm letting you know what the facts say
supreme court justice the facts show
that i'm not saying that i like him or
not like him
yeah but what are you saying that they
that that they're not
collecting the data correctly nowhere in
the united states constitution is row
mentioned at all you're talking about
row tyler i'm talking about clarence
thomas specifically but this is the
broader issue is everybody wants to talk
about roe right now okay you said 78 of
democratic women are more likely to vote
in the midterms i said 70 of democrats
yes as they should if you want federally
legal abortion vote on it
tell your congress people to codify row
in the constitution get two-thirds of
the country to vote on a constitutional
amendment it's not up to nine supreme
court justices to make the rules i will
say this to you if there is
uh uh
anybody in america right now that needs
security around them i know six people
that do and i know one that needs a lot
of people around them uh because just
the other day i don't know if you guys
saw now julian maxwell was put on
suicide watch i don't know how they make
the decision like that so that's another
news that could be changing anytime soon
why he was put on that she was put on
that suicide watch i don't know but i
hope the right
secret service you know
security protection is around those
you're talking about the supreme court
justices
right the guy who came by kavanaugh
that's right they need protection like
there is no tomorrow they need
protection anyways great podcast
excited to do this again roger thanks
for coming out rick thanks for coming
out thursday we're doing it again i'm on
this week twice
and uh uh a massive uh uh
think hap the biggest uh um exciting
thing in business ever happened this
week that we'll talk about on the third
year i'm excited for that and maybe you
gotta feel where you've been for the
last 10 days but it's not just where
we've been because people know where
we've been it's what's happened when
we've been away which i can't wait for
that folks to the members out there the
pbd podcast love you you guys are
constantly uh we're reading your stuff
what you're saying to everybody that
contributed today thank you and if you
enjoyed today's format
with rick prattle and roger stone cmo
aka
many different names we can give to the
guests that we had on today give us a
thumbs up subscribe to the channel and
let us know if you want to back on
because i know we're going to do this
again because the next 12 18 months is
going to be crazy we're going to want to
hear what they have to say take care
everybody bye-bye bye bye
you